la guerre froide à berlin fait grand
bruit mais c'est seulement lancer haut
parleurs américains et allemands de
l'est échange des rocs et les cha cha
cha par dessus les barbelés comme les
guerriers grecs jadis échanger des
injures c'est un progrès en revanche
larmes individuelle et silencieux c'est
la jumelle aux carrefours les
sentinelles des demandes ce fusille du
regard à bout portant et tout parent est
absurde au visiteur qui débarque comme
moi d'un pays civilisé absurde à la
mesure exacte de cette absurdité de
béton et de fer qui a poussé au milieu
de la ville en une seule nuit
le mur
[Musique]
cette nuit là le vieux monsieur
schumacher qui habite juste en face à
l'ouest dans meet encore d'un sommeil
léger je fus des veillées pendant la
nuit par les travaux vous avez entendu
du bruit j'ai naturellement je me suis
levé naturellement j'ai regardé par la
scène et j'ai regardé par la fenêtre
pour voir ce qui se passe
j'ai vu les ouvriers il fit le jour
n'est ce pas et qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé l'auteur rumeurs je pensais que
c'était un grand malheur pour tous les
deux partie de notre patrie respect et
qu'il ya beaucoup de langues est ce
qu'ils sont versés et ils seront encore
oui imaginez que d'un coup de sabre en
ouvre un homme en deux c'est s'avère
l'un chaque moitié soudain s'aperçoit
qu'elle a besoin de l'autre comme si un
autre mur invisible celui-là avait
traversé en une nuit les amours les
amitiés les familles regardez par
exemple cette scène entre une mère et
une fille la fillette à l'ouest la mer à
l'est elles pourraient encore se parler
mais elles ne sont pas seules à quelques
mètres de là il y a une voiture avec des
policiers de l'est alors la mère a peur
de se compromettre et elle s'en va
[Musique]
et le spectacle le plus hallucinantes
berlin s'étant secteur français à la
bernauerstrasse quand leur encontre
du côté est les maisons elles mêmes se
sont changés en mur les soupirail les
fenêtres ont été murées
alors chaque soir on assiste à une
grande migration l'est et l'ouest vont à
la rencontre l'un de l'autre vers ce mur
qui les force à lever la tête
les rendant étrangement semblables à des
poissons qui chercheraient de l'air sur
tous ces visages on peut mettre un nom
celui de l'autre visage de l'autre côté
du mur
quel est selon écouter mme alain matha
[Musique]
phénomène en france mais qui n'a pas
participé aux élections le 13 août cet
homme lui attendait sa mère qui habite
de l'autre côté écouter son histoire
votre mère habite l'est monsieur oui ma
mère habite le faubourg de bellaing a au
sud-est de la ville est la deuxième
région dès le 23 ou pourquoi le 23 parce
que c'était une date fixée par les
déménageurs le déménageur de l'est qui
seule est autorisée à faire le
déménagement dans le sens est ouest
oui et forcément le 23 que c'était la
seule date libre pour lui oui et
malheureusement ce sont les événements
du 13 ou wii qui se sont interposés
elle n'a pas pu venir par conséquent non
est-ce que vous avez su comment ça
s'était passé
oui eux ma mère n'a écrit deux lettres
entre temps et si vous le passage entre
23 août à le jour même où elle devait
venir
c'est aujourd'hui le jour où je devais
vous rejoindre chez un enfant mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas possible
hier j'ai vu le déménageur mais il n'a
pas l'autorisation de quitter le secteur
oriental
je suis tellement désespérée je suis
assise entre les deux entre les annaba
dont je bégaie je suis assise entre les
sacs les hamas a démenti
et puis écrit quelques phrases très
désespérée
exprime par action de 10 le plus
réveillé comme ça et c'est très
compréhensible parce que ça continue les
meubles sont vendus le logement est lui
à d'autres à d'autres rues à toute
personne ne le sait pas quoi faire
par cette bouche de métro il ya deux
mois quand j'étais déjà à berlin
milliers d'hommes et de femmes chaque
jour choisissez la liberté aujourd'hui
combien il en passe 10 20 il ne leur
reste pour s'évader que les soupirail et
les cordes
[Musique]
voici le récit de l'un de ces hommes que
le mur du lhb riesch n'a pas empêché de
passer
j'ai tous les frontières sont fermées
maintenant d'abord on était tellement
choquée qu'on ne pensais à rien quand on
commençait à penser c'était déjà trop
tard
on ne risquait la vie si on voulait
traverser encore cette frontière
c'est de pouvoir se dire une prison
c'est toujours la même chose
si si on est pour ainsi dire un
prisonnier on pense d'abord à la fuite
ça c'était aussi ce que j'ai fait
pendant la dernière semaine
je pense seulement à 7,8 j'ai regardé
chaque jour du matin jusqu'au soir le
plan de berlin pour trouver encore un
trou où je pouvais passer la frontière
j'ai visité aussi les frontières et
toutes ses frontières étaient tellement
gâtés que qu'on ne pouvait plus faire
qu'on ne pouvait plus s'enfuir
hier j'ai eu la chance de recevoir alors
une carte d'identité fausses
avec cette carte identité fausse g a
traversé cette frontière
j'ai eu peur je le dis tout franchement
mais si c'est toujours comme ça alors si
on veut travailler en quand je veux
étudier ici fédéral
et si on veut faire ça alors on risque
aussi la vie pour vivre dans la liberté
on parle beaucoup de la liberté mais en
ce moment là j'ai compris je crois bien
que j'ai compris pour la première fois
vraiment à 7
meaux ce mot la liberté ce que veut dire
la liberté au pied de cet immeuble de
l'est une femme s'est écrasé sur le
trottoir en voulant sauter désespérément
de sa fenêtre au troisième étage une
couronne dit aux passantes la liberté ce
prêt gêne pendant que nous cherchons à
voir de quelle fenêtre exactement elle
s'était jetée une étrange scène s'est
déroulée caractéristiques du climat du
mur garder dans l'appartement voisin de
celui de la morte un petit vieux nous
fait des signes il a compris ce que nous
cherchions
[Musique]
et maintenant regarder cette autre scène
un drame intérieur étonnant va s'y jouer
sous vos yeux
dans ce cimetière fermé côté ouest un
veau peau montent la garde entre les
tombes
regardez bien ce qu'il va faire
[Musique]
et oui les géôliers aussi s'évade sur ce
canal le même jour les sentinelles de
l'instant tiré un tué en s'évade aussi
aux pays d'où l'on ne revient pas
et celui là aussi évolué ces vingt
années avant la fermeture il parlait à
la télévision de l'ouest mais c'est à la
télévision ne laisse que les berlinois
n'ont vu ce soir-là en retransmettait
son procès aujourd'hui les berlinois ont
peur jusque ont-ils peur j'ai posé la
question à plusieurs d'entre eux un
médecin d'abord qui n'a voulu apparaître
que dans l'ombre
docteur ès que dans votre cabinet les
clients vous parle de la situation à
berlin sûrement il parle de la situation
d'abord qu'il parle de la maladie
est-ce que ils sont inquiets ils ont
d'un client aujourd'hui présent jours
sûrement et vous moi même un peu
un peu je suis vous avez peur comme
apparemment mais pour la famille pour
les enfants
naturellement aussi grimper parmi votre
clientèle est ce que vous connaissez les
berlinois qui quitte berlin
je connais grand part de clients une
bonne partie par partie de clients qui
ont déjà quitté berlin et qui y seront
aussi les berlinois bondi on aurait dû
dès le premier jour enlever les barbelés
qui ont été posées par les troupes de
l'est
est ce votre avis je crois ce serait été
oui une bonne idée au premier moment
seulement
et si on l'avait fait que serait-il
arrivé rien du tout est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura une guerre docteur
je ne suis pas sûrs qu'il n'y aura pas
une guerre d'une autre berlinoise
journaliste gabriel muller n'est pas
aussi bien ses maracas aujourd'hui
madame muller pour longtemps tous ces
semaines je travaillais beaucoup dans la
semaine passée et pour cela je vais
gagner mais backhaul ou partez
tranquille oui absolument
trop de quoi le pire est passé pour ben
n'est pas inquiète par conséquent on
n'avait pas peur n'aie pas vous savez je
suis restée à berlin pendant toute la
guerre je suis resté pendant la bataille
de berlin
et je suis resté lorsque les russes sont
venus
je suis resté pendant le blocus
pourquoi devrais je pas retenir mundo
oui je dois dire que tous les berlinois
que j'ai vu ne partage pas cette
assurance est votre calme
on m'a dit qu'on faisait beaucoup de
stocks de provisions dans les familles à
berlin il ya la wii mais pas dans ma
famille vous savez la semaine passée
un matin d'abord l'hymne venait dans le
mât plus d'un genre le dit pourquoi et
bien c'est nécessaire d'acheter du sucre
de la farine des bougies le de riz est
tout seul - stoke
non j'ai dit vingt graines dans ma
maison
ironie cette pancarte muret dis
bienvenue à berlin pendant huit jours
j'ai parlé ainsi les dizaines de
personnes ce qui les déchire au moins
autant que le mur c'est leur désarroi
devant l'avenir
madame hersberger je crois que vous
pensez qu'il faut négocier sur berlin
oui je crois au moment c'est la seule
aussi possibilité pourquoi pour éviter
la guerre je crains qu'on commence avec
négociations on est perdu est ce qui
vous donne cette confiance mal à müller
on
la confiance en les alliés on n'avait
pas confiance non de confiance je suis
optimiste rue moi je suis pessimiste
quant aux images muettes comment s'y
fier laquelle croit celle de ses ruelles
commerçantes de l'ouest proche du mur
d'où toute vie a fui comme d'une ville
abandonnée
[Musique]
on celle de ses matinée ensoleillée sur
le lac qui s'obstine à ne vouloir parler
que de bonheur
[Musique]
faut-il par ses meubles qui s'entassent
dans les entrepreneurs français qui
lisent le départ on sait send
enthousiasme à l'arrivée des soldats
américains dans berlin qui disent nous
restons
qui a raison des uns et des autres c'est
ce radar qui le dira sur son écran
atteint peu l'offre les américains
assistent minute après minute à tout ce
qui se passe dans le fameux couloir
aérien
s'il ya un incident c'est là qu'on verra
en premier
mais derrière cette façade où flottent
encore lent drapeau les rues sont
toujours là pour garantir qu'il ne se
passera rien s'ils partent carrie
bradshaw ici cette nuit par exemple les
hostilités se déclarer à berlin sous une
forme ou sous une autre
est-ce que vous personnellement
j'entends vous et vos hommes bien
entendu vous savez ce que vous avez
précisément à faire je sais
personnellement exactement ce que j'ai à
faire
les ordres
ne sont pas descendues jusqu'à l'échelon
le plus bas mais tous les cadres savent
exactement ce qu'ils ont à faire
il y a un plan il y a un plan et vous
personnellement vous le connaissez
affirmé que je connais mais ce plan
j'espère que personne d'entre nous amène
le connaîtra que les charges à perdre à
n'auront jamais de missions plus
guerrière que celle de cette auto
mitrailleuses anglaise qui escortent
chaque jour sur l'itinéraire contesté
par l'est
ce petit garçon allemand jusqu'à son
école
[Musique]